the afternoon session we're very happy
to have Kristoff Hearn here to present
on some very cool applications of
multiple calibration and uh this line of
work it's huge problems and Survey
statistics
yeah thank you very much I'm very happy
and excited to be here in in person
um so thanks for the organizers for
putting together this awesome Workshop
um yeah and so this is John Burke with
Angela show and Michael and we're
interested in robustifying Kate
estimation I'm using multi-accurate
learning
so uh motivation here is that basically
because of effect estimation is
important
um so especially we're looking here at
unpersonalized causal effect estimation
as a critical component to to cut Target
Precision support
and an example could come from the labor
market context which is where we have
done some some research and you could
just think about support programs that
might be available to job Seekers and we
might be not just interested in looking
at the overall effectiveness of a given
support program but also we might be
interested in heterogeneous treatment
effects
now um clearly there's a lot of work
that has been done on in this area
specifically we are here interested in
uh looking at
um unknown deployment settings so the
question of whether we'll be able to to
adapt uh personalized causal effect
estimates to to new settings
and uh specifically here again with this
example you might want to understand the
program effective Effectiveness in other
contexts and other contexts could just
be other countries right so Europe
there's this European network of public
employment services that are supposed to
learn from each other so the idea here
would be maybe one country runs a
program
and we want to want to understand
whether and how this program might work
out in in other countries
good and uh we will draw on previous
work on our uh work on universal
adaptability that is similarly kind of
following this setup so in in that
context or task or inference challenge
was that we are given one single Source
data and we're interested in making
inference on Downstream Target data that
may not look like the source data and
you potentially also have many different
targets
um and um sort of Target specific
approach to to yeah approach on this
problem would be
um simply using inverse propensity score
weighting essentially so that we would
model the shifts um between the single
source and the given Target
um at training time so that essentially
will be able to adapt to to this shifted
Downstream distribution
and we were interested um in this paper
in sort of moving towards a more Target
independent approach as opposed to this
very Target specific approach we would
have to kind of essentially build a new
to new propensity model for each Target
distribution
and uh to be a little bit more precise
of what we wanted to to achieve
um so we are kind of talking here about
a prediction approach so we are kind of
looking at a single predictor and we're
making some requirements uh as to how we
think about this predict and how it
would compare to Target specific
inference using propensity scoring so
what we see here essentially is that uh
or our goal of universal adaptability is
that we have this single Source
distribution we have a predictor that is
learned on the source distribution but
then the estimation error that is based
on this predictor P tilde is essentially
competitive with Target specific
propensity scoring so that that is sort
of our our goal here so that for each of
those targets Downstream we are able to
compete with this uh sort of
best-in-class
propensity scoring approach using this
single uh predictor picture
now how do we achieve this it turns out
uh
um quite nicely that multicolor braided
predictors are actually University
adaptable so we can use a
multi-calibrate predictor here as shown
in this this little sketch and
essentially pair it then Downstream with
different covariate distributions
and then if it would
let's compare this um widely calibrated
pretty good in the associated estimate
on all of those different targets we
would have some guarantees that this is
actually competitive to Target specific
inference using uh propensity scoring
that is tied to each individual Target
Downstream distribution
um so in this work we've thereby kind of
yeah established this this connection
between those two rather different goals
so the fairness goal where we're
interested in predicting subpopulations
from miscalibrated predictions
and and kind of explore this connection
to statistical inference when we
eventually want to ensure unbiased
estimates on multiple Downstream targets
yeah and um however in this work our
estimates were would all kind of
centered around this what I would call
descriptive inference so for the most
part we were interested in some um kind
of mean estimates on our Downstream
population or some estimate of some
prevalence which is now kind of I
immediately
um I'm pushing to this follow-up
question which is can we use this idea
of universal adaptability to essentially
robustify conditional average treatment
effect estimation as well so can we use
multi calibration in multiocracy to to
robustify and protect against shifts in
the context of Kate estimation
um so the case estimation setup is of
course are somewhat different to what we
did in Universal adaptability context so
we have our covariate we now have some
treatment indicator we have observed
outcomes but however we are for the most
part of course interested in the
potential outcomes
um so YT and our estimate of interest is
this Kate function we were essentially
kind of looking at the difference in the
potential outcomes given X so that
there's a sort of personalized in a
sense that given your your ex set in X
you would get potentially different
estimate for your treatment effect
right then of course we are drawing on
assumptions that are kind of standard
assumptions in the um causal inference
context of course most importantly this
unconfoundedness assumption which is
just saying that okay in our covariates
we do observe all of the potential
confounders that we might vary about
although actually later on WE to some
extent relax this assumption and see
what we could do in a uh let's say a
slightly different context
um
so then what do people do in this
context in order to learn this Kate
um there are of course a bunch of
approaches that have been proposed for
the most part here we will focusing on
the T learner which is rather let's say
a prediction approach to to solve this
problem so we have two steps we first
have
um this idea of Simply fitting treatment
conditional outcome regressions so for
our treated and untreated in the data
that we observe we are fitting um for
instance the random forest or something
else so we have those two arms that we
are establishing in order to learn the
respective outcome functions
and then we are imputing the respective
counterfactual outcome using those two
arms in order to estimate and the gate
function so that is sort of a make a
common approach
clearly um they are also more
sophisticated approaches that have been
proposed in this literature that are um
for us at this point maybe reference
methods but we're also moving towards
um
understanding whether we could also do
something about
pairing multi accuracy with with those
approaches but for now we'll just focus
on the simple t-learner setting
right and performance situation
um here we would for instance be
interested in looking at the MSE of
decade or bias although again our our
main thinking here is that we are
interested in understanding how this
might work under distributions that are
different than the distribution that we
would use during training time so it's
again the same idea as before and what
would happen if we have like a this
unknown shift during our deployment
in the deployment setting how do we
perform then under under shift
um
and let me also again like sketch this
higher level idea so this is the first
setting the external shift setting we
have given this um first set of um
unconformed data so with xt5 we are then
um trying to estimate the state function
and our idea for the most part here is
simply using mcboost auditing then in
order to robustify this initial Kate
learner such that during deployment time
we are protecting against a distribution
shift eventually
correctly jump into what we propose uh
to do so
um this is our
higher level algorithm or kind of
summarizing this rather simple idea
which is just saying as I just mentioned
so the input is our Observer
observational
data that is unconfounded we have some
auditor function class F we have our
function class that we would use for
outcome function modeling the outcome
functions
again in practice it could just be
starting some random Forest
and then the first step here is
essentially following this T learning
idea so we fit our two outcome uh
regressions
um for treated and untreated and then we
simply propose to post process both arms
of the T learner so the model for the
treated and the untreated I'm using
mcboost
um auditing for the most partly we'll
just draw on algae accuracy
um so we'll do multi-accuracy auditing
and such that this condition here holds
so that for every
subpopulation in F we are multi-accurate
on both arms now so this is like again
for those two outcome functions we are
quality accurate uh eventually
and we are then essentially using those
post-processed
um outcome functions to to return our
multi-accurate
t
totaled
um
a slightly different setting where we
are I'm essentially proposing a similar
idea but and this is now
um uh complicating things a little bit
so here now we say okay what if our
observational data is not unconfonement
such that there is some unobserved
confounding so this U variable here that
is not observed meaning that by just
using this observational study
um there's no hope to actually learn the
true outcome either the true Kate
function right so we're kind of um in
the unobserved confounding setting
however we also assume now here that
maybe we have access and addition to a
small randomized control trial so in
this case then
um we might be able to essentially
jointly learn from those two
data sets so again here the the
Assumption will be maybe this RCT data
is so small that it's also not possible
to efficiently replicate from just this
small RCT data so we want to kind of
Leverage sort of both data sets
um and we will do this again by using
mcboosting
um
essentially the the key ID here was
simply to say okay we'll warm starter T
learner on this observational data and
then we post process on the RCT data so
that was like the idea of connecting
those two pieces
um with then eventually the hope that we
will get rid of the bias that comes in
from the confounding in the
observational data and at the same time
uh positively correct or be robust
towards unknown unknown Downstream
coverage shifts
so for this
um also again like I'm just highlighting
this this simple idea so now we have
this confounded observational leaders
and put in addition to this small RCT
um again
um some auditor function class and and
function tasks for the outcome functions
we start now with learning uh building a
t-learner in the observational data set
um so we can have our two arms of the
t-learner and then the rcd data comes in
when it comes to
post-processing this initial T learner
for multi-accuracy again
with respect to those both arms the two
arms of BP learner and then eventually
we are again returning this
multi-calibrated towel function
reinterpret the like
the boosting test function as like uh
evidence of specific kind of compounding
or something because you're saying this
is the way that the traditional
expectation is most different from the
profound distribution
after the fact
um
you will get a test function which is
like the
as like evidence or a particular type of
grounding structure
I think it's not like consider that at
this point
even shaking like how much like
technical recording the number of
operations and it's needed yeah
yeah okay yeah
foreign
so I'm just summarizing a little bit of
what we can see at this point so um some
main characteristics of this
multi-accurate uh post-processed KT Nana
so first we can establish a Do no harm
property with respect to the MSE saying
that essentially comparing to the the
Best in Class T inanna we are at least
compatible or competitive with respect
to MSE
and to to that testing Class 2 learner
and also then in addition of course we
want to to see some bias guarantees with
respect to those online known shifts and
in order to establish those we
essentially assume that we are able to
capture sort of a rich class
um in our auditing function that include
two pieces so C here which is including
or indexing the subgroups that are
relevant for decayed estimation and also
H which is relevant to capture the
downstream shift so if we're able to
essentially
um yeah assume that our auditing
functions include the product class of
those then we are able to establish this
this bias guarantee that is saying okay
on all of those Downstream distributions
we are sort of
um in a safe space with respect to bias
foreign
so um we have uh run quite a few
simulations to to see not only whether
this initial idea works out but also
compared to other approaches that are
common
um and the setup is we are starting with
simulating of course our
XT and y's we also then know the true
page function that we can compare
against
and then we are
um also sampling from this initial
distribution with weights to introduce a
shift in the coverage distribution
and we do this um by by following this
external shift function that is uh
including also a different shift
intensities so that we can compare
against like over a range of off shift
how how
um how strongly this this guarantee
actually holds
um and then again those two two settings
to be a little bit more precise with
what we did here so setting One external
shift and observational data only no no
unobserved by founding
um we are training on this initial OS
distribution we have an initial an
additional small auditing sample from
the same distribution again we're kind
of that's important so we don't want to
cheat here so we're kind of auditing on
the same Source distribution and then
the the deployment distribution also the
test data here is shifted so that that
is where we then evaluate and the CE and
bias and all of the things
for setting two
um
observational data and small shifted RCT
we have this an addition uh this
additional unobserved confounding in the
observational data
um and um here now the training happens
on this first
dos distribution we are then proposing
as I mentioned earlier to to audit on
the RCT here the rcd is also shifted in
in the coverage distribution away from
the OS
and then we're again back and
um evaluating MSE and bias on test data
that comes from the original
distribution although we could also have
like an additional shift for this
deployment and data but for now this is
just a sort of predicting like the the
observational distribution
right
um
I am
uh comparing to
um yeah for now to reference approaches
so um we are comparing against called
the forest
in both settings uh called the forest
changed on the observational training
data alone
then of course we are comparing against
the unprocessed T learner so um our kind
of initial um trainer in this case using
random Forest creating the observational
training data and then
um we are interested of course in
evaluating how our combined approach
works so we have our team owner mcrich
which is using this initial T learner
post process with mcboost using in this
case Rich regression in this auditing
set
and um here for setting two again called
the forest deal on a anti learner MC3
where now the post-processing happens
with decision trees in the RCT data but
also this is just for just picking
things here we also did the tree post
processing and Bridge process
post-processing and setting two and one
as well and also there are more things
that we compared against for instance
um we also compared against sort of
re-rated cause of forests and we rated T
learner where we were kind of first
um estimating a propensity score in
order to to then correct for the shift
and essentially we rate the source data
so that it looks like the target data
and again trying to learn on top of that
although of course that needs access to
the downstream data at a training time
so this is sort of a strong Baseline
um
um what do we see so um this is the MSC
over a multiple sum assimilation runs
um in the no shift setting we don't
expect to see anything surprising so
clearly there there's uh it's just
showing that mcrich here on top of key
learner doesn't hurt at least
and then the main findings that moving
to this moderate shift or strong shift
setting especially if we are training uh
with sort of a modest size of initial
observational data post-processing this
initial team and uh with mcrich
um improves and um Mac in the downstream
distribution to some extent whether this
is a significant Improvement is maybe up
to you to decide but we do see some
improvements
um
um especially in those settings where we
have limited initial data and there's
also maybe some some improvement also
later on but for the most part you see
the biggest boost there
um for setting two so again this is
jointly learning in the observational
data and the RCT there's a little bit of
an additional
um
performance Gap and we see so um also
here in the no shift setting reminder
here that the shift the data is you know
the RCT so the RCT is shifted away
so meaning that also we would here now
she see something interesting in the no
shift setting across here again and the
the rcd data is the data that is
allowing us to learn and confounded
Gates and meaning that here actually
there's a
let's say it's a significant Improvement
if we compare the original blue
t-learner to our post-processed
t-learner which is the degree
mass and this is also consistent then if
we move
um
the key data away from the
in x
although we also do see that it's it's
hard to hear to off-the-shelf compete
against cause of forest at this point
concluding here so our idea was to to to
see whether we can robustify k2t
learning and to announce shifts use AMC
boost processing
um also this this other setting was kind
of and trying to learn uh jointly from
observational data and RCT by by
utilizing mcboosting and we do see some
improvements in bias and MSC in our
simulations at this point we also did a
real world really data application that
has sort of in line with what we've seen
in the simulations although it's also
important to note at this point that
it's
um our multi-kate approach is sort of
robust but it's not as efficient such
that for instance it's it's hard to
complete uh competing against uh
Learners that are kind of optimized for
reducing bias such as causal foreign
right but I also wanted to to stress
here that clearly this is an area where
it can have a lot of work is has been
proposed our Focus here was for the most
part to just push this idea and then see
whether we can use multi-accuracy in
multi
um calibration to
off-the-shelf uh manner to to
um and adapt it to this gate estimation
domain so and this is sort of a an
ongoing research and we hope to to
um to move this further
and yeah so that that was sort of the
the main takes aways and I also wanted
to just at the end stress that since we
all learned that uh what we all that we
need is multi-calibration we uh develop
an r package so also wanted to just
make sure that that this is out there
and people know that this exists and we
are also clearly happy to receive any
feedback on this
um
and yeah I think it has a rather
straightforward interface so what you
can do you can essentially use your plug
in your your favorite uh ml model
um we have some predefined auditing
um algorithms but you can also use
something else there and then you
basically just need two or three lines
of codes to
um multi-calibrate your model and then
use it Downstream for whatever you like
right
um yeah that's it from me thank you very
much
for the package uh do you have are there
a lot of like hyper parameters like do
you have to specify number
you can so it's it's um yeah that's all
like something that that can be
specified so you can also say okay I'm
also hot uh yeah
um and also so think about this as a
tuning problem maybe so that is that is
included you're also include like things
like cross validation on on the auditing
set so that you're not sort of
always fitting with your
um in the collaboration context but yeah
so that that is all
um possible to adjust and so for the
actual experiment did you have to
optimize for this where it kind of like
worked out oh yeah actually we sort of
were rather let's say agnostic here and
sort of mostly used like being into
setting of like the standard setting let
me just opted for in the package
um
setting so yeah that was not like it too
much like optimization
last questions
uh so how sensitive were these results
to the choice of auditing in algorithm
yeah so as I mentioned so we
did use 3DS any retrogation in those
settings
and I would just now say it was it is
similar I think I am sort of reporting
retro version here and three regression
just to not have everything on one side
um but the settings are different right
so it's it was similar in both settings
for both methods oh yeah
so no yeah yeah
and also what I do remember is that we
like there's like a just a limited
number of rounds that actually was
needed here so it's not that this is
like not running mcfalling I think he
wants or something which is like minor
minor post processing and we always see
like those differences
okay great let's thank Krista
foreign